[Music]
now is this true that you're writing a
vespa now i am i'm a proud vesper
anybody right investor nobody nobody um
i should have told you this is this is i
should've told you this is hell's angels
night at the show
it's all hell's angels here i am not
ashamed i love that anyone here write a
best book there's a silence you don't
hear in deep space
it's such it gets such a bad rap in this
in this country you know of course in
europe you automatically get laid you
look at the french bread and the wine
you know it's it's a sexy thing here
it's it's they laughed at you but the
problem is the scale of the united
states is so massive you know you get on
the 405 freeway like
two cylinders
but at least it's i mean there's you
never hear bad stories about vespa you
know you never hear that guy said you
hear about tom
yeah i rolled his scooter man rolled it
right over
it's
i don't imagine i can't really imagine
you you doing the scootery thing no i
don't think i could do the scooter well
also my body is so weird i'm very long i
think the you know i'd be it'd be like
am i pedaling on a vespa
but i i just went you think of vespa's a
tricycle don't you
you don't know we're talking about
tricycles here
that was a little ringling brothers
right it was i was in the circus uh
let's talk about perception perception's
doing very well i'm proud to say we're
the same family it's a tnt show mondays
at 10. you guys are uh having a good
time a terrific show you're you even
tweet this is the world we're in now
they've got you tweeting during the the
shows as the show airs you tweet and
live to live tweeting which i've been
excited to do because i've been in
canada for the summer so i'm actually
not seeing the show so i feel like i'm
connecting with the fans but i'm
connecting
while they're watching it you know so
they'll literally be tweeting me what's
going to happen after the commercial
i'll be like well
watch the show i'm not going to i'm not
going to tell you right
i can't wait
i need to know it is an instant
gratification society now
it's like i must have access to you at
all times where will you be in 45
minutes yes
what are you wearing
oh you're getting those oh sure and uh
you know and i love you know right at
the height of the climax of of the
episode some little treat
god i miss will and grace like are you
watching the show
i'm staying up stop it
i'm a different character now not now
but uh you know monday's at 10. when
does grace come over
he's not coming over
uh all right we have a clip here and uh
and and i don't know exactly which clip
this is i know that you are helping the
fbi you are a neuro i'm i'm a
neuroscience professor i shouldn't be
solving crimes but a next student of
mine the beautiful rachel lee cook uh is
constantly coming every week as a matter
of fact to say there's a crime
convenience this is another problem
i need your help for exactly an hour is
it monday
i can't solve this
and uh and this is one where it turns
out that uh the guy that i've been
listening with is another professor at
the university with me and i know that
he's uh he's done something to get
scholarship money or something all right
let's take a look at this clip from
perception
can i help you i'm dr daniel pierce
department of neuroscience this is agent
probert of the fbi fbi what's this about
this conversation's private
i assume you heard about kelly owens the
girl who died on campus today yeah it's
terrible it should have been you
excuse me you were the target
what's your connection to frederick
defoe apart from the fact that you hold
a chair generously endowed by his
foundation what the hell is this look
either you talk to me or i get a guy out
there to phone his body's the bureau and
then it's the handcuffs the all-night
interrogation sweating in a damp cell
until you finally break and spill it
anyway all in all i'd say your best bet
is talking to me now what did you do for
frederick the foe that got you the
endowed chair
[Applause]